[Musica]
vabbè alla fine della fiera un po di
bene noi lo vogliamo ma quel bene che
vogliamo
se avete quei parenti acquisiti qui e
fanno tanta tenerezza però non te lo
porteresti mai una cerimonia elegante no
perché hai paura e parlo del nostro inno
e vedete il nostro inno si gli vogliamo
bene lo sentiamo nostro però è brutta
rire un brutto età giunta zoom e quello
che si chiama una marcetta incomparabile
rispetto ai sontuosi né degli altri e
parlare bene del nostro in come come
dire cominciare a intraprendere i
sentieri più impervi della filosofia
eleatica è come cercare di dimostrarvi
che ad esempio questa donna è un'attrice
o che per dire questo è stato il modello
di auto migliore della storia
dell'industria automobilistica del
ventesimo secolo
eccola qua oggi vorrei dirvi una cosa
che noi abbiamo un grande inno che ha un
solo difetto è suonato da cani o meglio
non è eseguito come lo scrisse nel 1847
un signore che si chiamava michele
novaro il nostro inno ce l'abbiamo senza
istruzioni per l'uso
guardate io ho fatto parte di quel
gruppetto di persone che aiutò suo tempo
in un'altra vita al presidente ciampi
nel rinnovare rivitalizzare i simboli
della patria e nel 2002 il corriere
della sera ha distribuito a ciascun suo
lettore il 2 giugno
questo cd al quale io ho tolto la
copertina per carità di patria né
primaria banda militare una cantante
sette versioni dell'inno la numero 4
credetemi sulla parola
recita così versione integrale ridotta
no tu rimani un po così basito comincia
a pensare ai tuoi trascorsi scolastici
presa in meno meno però diobono se
integrali però l'ha detto al corriere
della sera vai avanti numero 5 versione
originale breve quindi c'è anche una
versione originale lunga ma quando
arriviamo al numero 6 versione integrale
ridotta originale tu chiami sos mago
otelma entri nelle praterie della magia
nera
allora abbiamo un bellino adesso vi
chiedo di chiudere un attimo gli occhi
no meglio
sgombrate namente cancellate dalla
vostra testa l'inno come siete abituati
ad ascoltarlo e sentite questa versione
che ho registrato al palazzo del
quirinale
diversi anni fa in occasione di una
visita di stato a eseguirla la banda
dell'esercito sentirete anche gli
zoccoli dei cavalli dei corazzieri e poi
ci torniamo
è un po strano non sembra neanche quello
che per cento cammina e fluido e
dinamico
posso dirvi che solenne e come lo
avvertiamo invece il nostro inno adesso
così
[Musica]
[Applauso]
direbbe un cuoco c'è un'idea di
percussione abbiamo ingessato l'inno
l'inno così linux è un abisso notte e
giorno
qual è il motivo il motivo è
semplicemente questo
purtroppo siamo l'unico paese al mondo
che fa marciare la nostra bandiera
sulle note dell'inno nazionale ed è per
questo abbiamo dovuto accentuare la
grancassa per permettere al gruppo
bandiera di tenere il passo
[Musica]
se eseguito da fermo
non ci sarebbe storia city
[Musica]
e con gli sulle pause ma va bene
in questa anarchia ci sono anche degli
inserimenti costose che adesso vi
propongo l'inno modello sagra paesana fa
sentire che mangiamo
[Musica]
ciao
senza
poi arrivò il genio si sveglia un
momento e disse ho capito qual è il
problema del nostro inno è troppo veloce
e scrisse l'inno soporifero
[Musica]
non pago un braccio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
signori se avevamo questi non stavamo
ancora sotto l'austria oggi adesso
vi voglio dire una cosa il nostro inno
sapete cos'è tecnicamente si chiama
cabaletta cioè il finale d'atto suoni la
tromba e intrepido questo è un finalone
d'atto cabaletta al tenore si scatena
applausi a scena aperta giù il sipario e
si riparte
com'è possibile perché è un finale dato
perché la musica del teatro d'opera
informava tutto il mondo musicale
ottocentesco non c'è la musica colta
musica popolare tutto stava lì e io vi
presento il genio michele novaro colui
che compose la musica del nostro inno
attenzione il nostro inno non è mogol
battisti bardotti shapiro cioè michele
novaro e goffredo mameli non lavorarono
insieme michele novaro riceve il testo
del nostro inno e lo legge e michele
novaro lavorava a torino nei teatri
sapete che significa lavorare nei teatri
nell'ottocento avere chiara l'idea della
scena del movimento della trama delle
masse che si muovono to vedevi un testo
e lo trasformava in azione e lui questo
fece vide il testo e scrisse la
partitura spalancò la porta del caffè
calosso in via garibaldi a torino e ai
suoi amici disse correte ho appena
composto la poesia di goffredo via tutti
una ventina della sua stanzetta in via
roma ma prima di immergere le dita del
pianoforte
lui si girò e disse ragazzi amici
scusate
perdonatemi sì sto per dire una
stupidaggine una pazzia ma vi voglio
dire che cosa mi ha ispirato diversi
qual è la scena che mi è entrata nella
testa e che io ho tradotto in partitura
e la vediamo noi adesso soprattutto che
la musica non la conosce lui e dice mi
pareva di essere in un immensa pianura
riempita all'inverosimile di tutte le
popolazioni italiane 24 milioni di
italiani che stanno in una pianura a
dire cosa non lo so anche tu qui perché
non lo so
improvvisamente rulli di tamburo e
squilli di tromba attenzione allegro
marziale che non vuol dire tempo di
marzo vuol dire fiero solenne forte duro
come inizia il nostro inno con un
segnale d'allarme
rulli di tamburi e squilli di tromba
sentite tamburi che si ripetono ancora e
le trombe richiamano provate invece
stare in mezzo a questa gente è
cominciare che qualcuno mi strattona
diciamo quarta la giusy è lo sguardo
delle persone va in un angolo di questa
pianura dove c'è un trono e sul trono
una personaggio meravigliosamente
vestito che si alza in piedi allarga le
braccia e novaro dice con queste braccia
pareva che volesse abbracciare tutta
quella popolazione e comincia a parlare
questo movimento degli sguardi delle
persone e la figura che si alza le
braccia che si levano è rappresentato in
partitura da questo pezzettino in cui
lui segna vibrato vedete quello era vuol
dire suonatelo con espressione
[Musica]
avete notato che ci sono due battute
d'attesa perché devi accentuare
l'aspettativa che cosa dice non li
tagliamo sempre una spesso bestie non si
fa non si fa e adesso questa figura
comincia a parlare ma come parla
c'è scritto lassù lo dice f con molta
energia forte con montegiardino nei
fratelli d'italia fratelli d'italia
l'italia s'è adesso io devo convincere
24 milioni di straccioni gli ultimi
dell'europa divisi in sette stati
calpesti e derisi a prendere le armi
contro l'austria e quindi il mio canto è
solenne chi sa la musica guardi la
sottigliezza e la bravura di pause e
legature e spingono dinamicamente questo
canto
[Musica]
si no
no
[Musica]
no no
orca miseria e adesso il colpo di genio
di novaro quello che noi traduciamo un
po po po po po po po po po che non è
poco
queste note ribattute che vedete in
fondo a destra sapete cosa sono
l'effetto di quelle parole sul cuore
della gente sono dei pugni sullo stomaco
[Musica]
e adesso cambia tutto vi ricordate prima
allegro marziale forte con molta energia
allegromosso pianissimo e molto
concitato cambia qualcosa noi siamo
abituati a ricantare uguale fra l italia
no no no no è sbagliato e sbagliato noi
siamo l'unico paese al mondo che ha un
inno in cui protagonisti sono due una
voce che chiama è un popolo che risponde
da questo momento sui 24 milioni di
straccioni che parlano e quando tu
ricevi una notizia che è incredibile a
cui tu non credi quante volte noi
abbiamo ripetuto con un punto
interrogativo ma veramente mi stai
dicendo che è successo semplicemente
questo noi ripetiamo la strofa perché il
popolo non ci crede e la ripete con un
punto di interrogativi incredulo la
gente ha paura c'è niente di eroico vado
[Musica]
si affaccia l'idea del combattere ma c'è
anche l'idea della morte il tono rimane
minore e c'è ancora paura
[Musica]
poi il miracolo guardate in partitura
crescendo accelerando fino alla fine in
questo momento il popolo capisce che può
farcela acquisisce la consapevolezza e
rompe le indugi accelera si alza la voce
si alza e grida quel sì che non c'è
nella poesia ma che michele novaro dice
mi perdonerà il poeta molo aggiunto come
suggello al giuramento finale sentite
che bello
[Musica]
signori nel minuto della prima strofa
dell'inno c'è tutto il nostro
risorgimento e adesso vorrei provare a
chiedervi una cosa vogliamo provare a
cantarla come la scritta michele novaro
ci proviamo ok allora tutti in piedi dai
dai segui teme che vi aiuto
seguitemi
[Musica]
lo sapevo che lì andiamo dal viceré
austriaco a fare l'inchino il primo
della forte con molta energia al fra
sarà pure laico che i frati
[Musica]
via
d
ansa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]